and Aid organizations in Sudan also say
they're monitoring increased violations
against women and girls they say victims
are being kidnapped from cartoon and
then being sold in several areas of
Darfur
one youth group says that fighters from
the rapid support forces are involved it
says it's concerned that the violations
could also extend to the rest of the
country well let's go to our
correspondent Heber Morgan in the
capital Khartoum hear about the
situation in Darfur has been
deteriorating for months can you give us
a sense of what's happening there now
well while most of the violence over the
past few months has been focused in West
Darfur this time we're seeing increased
violence as fighting continues between
the Sudanese Army and the paramilitary
rapid support forces in South Darfur
specifically in the city of Nyala now
there are still many civilians who are
uh who stay behind in unable to flee
from the conflict uh between the two
sides the Darfur Bar Association said
that 16 civilians were killed including
a family where nearly all of the family
members were killed with the exception
of one and they say that those who have
fled to displacement camps are not safe
either and that they're concerned that
other people who have been previously
displaced as a result of the fighting in
Darfur that has been ongoing for 20
years will not have anywhere to go to so
they've urged both sides to end the
fighting to protect civilian lives but
they say that the fighting does continue
that as civilians remain to be caught up
in the crossfire falling as casualties
as a result of the fighting with nowhere
to go to as especially because the
violence seems to be surrounding them
from every side and we know that
fighting is also continuing not only in
Darfur but elsewhere in the country too
yes we've seen airstrikes here in the
capital Khartoum Lisbon extracts in the
northern part of the capital there's
also airstrikes in the southern parts of
the capital between uh Khartoum and
Jazeera State that's a state in the
central part of Sudan Sudanese Army
sources say that they were targeting a
convoy of the paramilitary rapid support
forces that were trying to head to the
central part of the country sources also
said that the rsf carried out a drone
attack here in umdurman targeting an
army position killing at least four and
wounding many of us they say that they
also launched airstrikes against the
positions where the Drone took off from
in the northern part of the capital and
these are sounds that we can hear
regularly these are artilleries being
fired from the city of Underman towards
the northern part of the capital so it's
not only Darfur that is right now being
engulfed in the fighting the capital
Khartoum is also witnessing continued
fighting between the two sides Heather
Morgan there with the latest force from
the ground in the Sudanese capital thank
you so much stay safe